All right. The question was which of these five strings are in the language of this grammar.
The first one looks pretty good. I just apply rule 1.
P goes to open P close and then rule two to get rid of the P, and I'm in like Flynn.
How about this? Well, I'm going to apply rule one twice.
I'll end up with open open P close close, and then I'll use rule two to get rid of the P.
Similarly, over here I'm going to apply rule one three times.
Open open open P close close close.
Then I'll apply rule two to get rid of the P.
Totally in the language of our grammar.
But this--tsk, tsk, tsk--this is going to be problematic.
Just an open parenthesis.
If you look over here, there's actually no way to make just a lonely open parenthesis
that does not have a matching close parenthesis.
There's only one rule that introduces the open parenthesis,
and it makes just as many close parentheses at the same time.
This cannot happen. Here this looks good.
These parentheses match, open close open close,
but if you take a look at this grammar, there is never a way to have an open after a close.
I can apply this rule as many times as I want in this pattern,
but I'm never going to end up making something like this--not as written.
We could write a grammar for this, but not currently shown.
This sort of system is known a balanced parentheses.
The parentheses are balanced, because the number on the left equals the number on the right.
One to one, two to two, three to three.
In fact, you could imagine some sort of scale that'd have to be exactly equal--
two openings, two closings. Balanced parentheses.
This is a super-important problem in computer science.